und in unserem tagesgespräch begrüße ich
joachim stamp er ist stellvertretender
ministerpräsident des landes
nordrhein-westfalen und vorsitzender der
fdp in nordrhein westfalen
er stammt sie haben ja lange und
eigentlich sehr vertrauensvoll mit armin
laschet zusammengearbeitet dass es nun
geschichte was erwarten sie denn von
seinem nachfolger
ich erwarte mir die gleiche
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit auch mit
hendrik wüst wir haben uns ja intensiv
ausgetauscht arbeiten ja auch seit
jahren sehr gut miteinander im kabinett
zusammen und deswegen bin ich natürlich
auf der einen seite traurig über das
ende der zusammenarbeit mit armin
laschet aber ich freue mich auf die
zusammenarbeit mit hendrik wüst erwarten
sie keinerlei kursänderung es ist ja ein
neuer mensch mit neuen ansichten
ja es ist ein neuer mensch aber wir
haben ja einen klaren koalitionsvertrag
und wir haben ja auch darüber schon im
vorfeld gesprochen dass wir themen
voranbringen wollen wie den kinderschutz
dass wir in dieser legislaturperiode
noch ein plan schaffen wollen wie wir zu
erleichterungen kommen wollen bei der
grunderwerbsteuer speziell für junge
familien beim erwerb des ersten
eigentums ist glaube ich eine ganz
wichtige frage für viele
junge familien und wir werden auch ein
modernes versammlungsrecht gemeinsam auf
den weg bringen also wir sind inhaltlich
gut verabredet und personell passt
zwischen uns das heißt sie klingt
zuversichtlich
sie haben ja als koalition nur eine
stimme mehrheit im parlament
glauben sie dass das im ersten wahlgang
klappen wird das ist ja die große frage
bei ihnen düsseldorf
ja wir haben in fast viereinhalb jahren
keine einzige abstimmung verloren und
das wird auch diesmal so sein gut dann
sind wir sehr gespannt blicken wir
einmal nach berlin herrschte sie sind ja
als fdp-politiker quasi auch mit im
großen und ganzen am tisch jetzt haben
die grünen schon heute einen ersten
block eingerammt eine grünen abgeordnete
hat gefordert dass im rheinland das ja
auch ihr beritt ist kein dorf mehr den
kohletagebau weichen soll was sagen dazu
ich mische mich in die gespräche der
gruppe die klimaschutz und energie
bespricht nicht ein ich habe die
verantwortung für den bereich migration
hat horst seehofer eine große baustelle
hinterlassen wir müssen sehen wie wir
die irreguläre migration reduzieren und
dafür auf der anderen seite eine
gezielte einwanderung hier für den
arbeitsmarkt ermöglichen weil viele
handwerksbetriebe viele kleine und
mittlere unternehmen verzweifelt nach
arbeitskräften suchen und hier müssen
wir eine neue systematik erarbeiten und
gleichzeitig wissen wir sehen dass wir
eben beispielsweise straftäter und
gefährde viel konsequenter noch zurück
führen also was in der vergangenheit
passiert ist dh das ist ihre forderung
als fdp an die gruppe in berlin ein
neues einwanderungsgesetz habe ich das
jetzt richtig verstanden
das ist einer der punkte über die wir
uns unterhalten werden das was wir dort
ein inhalten besprechen bleibt intern
das werden wir dann am ende den medien
vorstellen da bitte ich einfach herzlich
auch um verständnis es würde mal gefragt
warum ist das notwendig eine solche
diskussion das geht einfach darum dass
wir nicht tagesaktuell irgendwelche
diskussionen wollen wer hat hier
nachgegeben der hat dort nachgegeben der
setzt sich durch wer ist möglicherweise
verlierer oder gewinner das sind alles
diskussionen die nicht hilfreich sind
sondern wir müssen in den themenfeldern
überzeugende antworten gemeinsam
entwickeln und das werden wir in großer
professionalität tun und deswegen bin
ich optimistisch dass wir auch einen
neustart in der migrationspolitik
hinbekommen werden das verstehe ich das
hat ja bisher auch gut geklappt weil die
runden klein war nun sind es 22 runden
mit entsprechend vielen menschen in
diesen gruppen das heißt sie können die
diskretion doch gar nicht waren oder
das ist eine frage des
verantwortungsbewusstseins einer jeden
verhandlerin und eines jeden verhandler
in diesen teams ich kann für meinen
bereich sagen dass ich den anspruch habe
dass wir das in der
notwendige professionalität und
diskretion
miteinander besprechen und ich hoffe
dass das in den anderen teams genauso
sein wird er jetzt weiß ich sie sind
migration das habe ich verstanden aber
trotzdem sind sie ja ein führender fdp
politiker und robert habeck hat gewirkt
so zusagen für mehr mut zur verschuldung
muss ihn als fdp-politiker sich noch ein
bisschen der magen umdrehen oder das ist
ja sozusagen ihrer kernklientel an
wähler gar nicht zu vermitteln
ja aber ich kommentiere jetzt nicht
einzelne aussagen das wird in den
entsprechenden fachgruppen gesprochen
werden und dann werden wir die
entsprechenden lösungen dann auch
präsentieren
muss aber trotzdem auch nochmal
natürlich die kernfrage die jetzt über
allem schwebt stellen die ministerien
werden ja auch besprochen wie viele
ministerien können sie sich davor
stellen für ihre partei und vor allem in
dieses jahr auch die große frage das
finanzministerium es kann ja eigentlich
für sie kein anderes wichtiges
ministerium geben
da muss ich sie enttäuschen über
ministerien wird im moment überhaupt
noch nicht gesprochen sondern wir haben
einen ganz klaren fahrplan dass du über
die großen reform themen sprechen in den
22 gruppen und dass wir uns über inhalte
unterhalten und ich glaube ist es
wichtig dass hier insgesamt vielleicht
mal ein ein neuer ton in die politische
kultur kommt dass es weniger
berichterstattung gibt über die frage
wer wird irgendwie wo was das ist immer
besonders spannend weil man das mit
menschen und mit bildern verbinden kann
aber in wahrheit geht es auch darum ob
wir die inhaltlichen themen gelöst
bekommen und natürlich ist da eine ganz
große frage wie wir den
menschengemachten klimawandel
entsprechend eindämmen können so wie wir
es uns vorgenommen haben wie wir die
bildungspolitik
wirklich umfassend voranbringen können
wie wir das rentenproblem
gemeinsam lösen und vor allem wie wir
bei der digitalisierung so vorankommen
dass wir nicht international den
anschluss verlieren das sind enorme
herausforderungen und die kann man nur
mit höchster sachlichkeit und präzision
besprechen und nicht indem
die karrierepläne im vordergrund stehen
alles klar ich danke ihnen herr stamm
für das gespräch und wünsche ihm viel
glück anfangen dezember wollen sie ja
schon fertig sein
ich danke ihnen